I know some people try to draw a line
and say well some animals are this and
other animals are not and there are
differences across species but all
species all individuals within a species
deserve to be treated with respect and
compassion as individuals
I see everything on a continuum I see
psychological continuity between humans
and the other animals and across
dolphins and primates and that simply
reflects the fact that evolution works
by building upon existing structures and
processes so that's reflected in the
fact that we all share a common
psychology and each species each if
you're an individual no matter whether
you're a dolphin or a monkey or a person
or an aardvark you have that basic
psychology that's just changed a little
bit depending upon what species you are